Un romance en el trabajo puede ser un tema complicado.
(Música)
[La forma en que trabajamos]
¿Cómo manejamos los límites
entre nuestras vidas personales y profesionales?
¿Cómo lidiamos con desequilibrios de género y dinámicas de poder en el trabajo?
Hay mucha zona gris en los romances en el trabajo.
Me tomaré unos minutos para responder algunas preguntas frecuentes.
Pregunta uno:
¿Debo salir con mi compañero de trabajo?
Ah... depende.
¿Quieres salir con tu compañero de trabajo para divertirte,
para tener una relación ocasional?
Porque si es así, te conviene Tinder.
Si quieres salir con tu compañero de trabajo
porque sinceramente crees que te estás enamorando
o hay potencial real para una relación comprometida a largo plazo,
quizá podrías salir con él.
Estudios muestran que tus compañeros de trabajo
tienen en general una actitud positiva si perciben que te estás enamorando
y lo haces de forma sincera.
Cuando sus compañeros sienten que algo más está en juego,
entonces puede ser disruptivo.
Pregunta dos:
¿Debo salir con mi jefe?
En casi todos los casos, no, no debes salir con tu jefe,
porque ahora hay una dinámica de poder.
Cuando hay una relación entre jefe y subordinado,
esto genera muchos sentimientos negativos,
que suelen proyectarse sobre la persona que está más abajo en el escalafón.
La gente suele suponer que hay algún favoritismo,
algún tipo de conocimiento interno,
y se pueden despertar resentimientos.
Un estudio publicado el año pasado sugiere
que salir con un superior puede incluso tener un impacto negativo en tu carrera.
Los investigadores solicitaron a evaluadores externos en línea
que imaginaran que trabajaban en un bufete de abogados.
Les pidieron que eligieran un empleado
para un programa de capacitación especial y otro para ser ascendido a socio.
Miraron credenciales de empleados imaginarios,
y cuando se decía que un empleado había salido
o estaba en una relación con un superior,
los evaluadores no tendieron a elegir a esa persona
para el programa de capacitación o para el ascenso,
incluso si tenían las mismas credenciales
de alguien que no estaba saliendo con su jefe.
Además, los evaluadores no tardaron en desestimar sus logros.
Pregunta tres:
¿Puedo salir con alguien que me informe?
Sigue siendo un gran "no".
Puede que no sientas que realmente eres el jefe, ¿verdad?
Pero lo eres, y hay allí una dinámica de poder que no se da en otras parejas.
Si realmente crees que hay una conexión personal sincera,
sería duradero y significativo.
Uno de los dos quizá deba moverse,
y no siempre debe ser la persona más abajo en el orden jerárquico de la empresa.
Cuarta pregunta:
Empecé a salir con un compañero de trabajo.
¿Cómo manejamos las cosas?
Es una pregunta muy común.
"¿Están saliendo? ¿Sí o no?".
No lo mantengas en secreto.
No tienes que entrar en el tema, pero el secreto tiende a ser corrosivo.
La gente tiende a ver a las parejas en el trabajo como una coalición o unidad,
por eso hay que aclarar a los compañeros que la pareja y uno no piensan igual.
Se aman, pero pueden estar en desacuerdo.
Pregunta cinco:
¿Por qué los compañeros de trabajo a menudo se atraen?
La respuesta obvia es que las personas tienden a sentirse atraídas
cuanto más tiempo pasen juntas.
Pero hay otro ingrediente que agregar:
la atracción tiende a suceder
cuando hay trabajo que exige una colaboración estrecha.
Imagina que tienes un proyecto en un grupo grande con un plazo ajustado
y trabajas hasta tarde en la noche e intercambian ideas.
Miras hacia arriba y al otro lado de la mesa,
uno de tus colegas tiene una gran idea.
Puedes sentir algo, y eso es natural.
A esta tarea la llamamos interdependencia.
Es terreno propicio para la atracción.
La segunda razón por la cual las personas en el trabajo se atraen
es que a menudo son similares.
Hay dos viejos adagios:
"Dios los cría y ellos se juntan" y "Los opuestos se atraen".
Pues bien, las investigaciones psicológicas sugieren que...
Dios los cría y ellos se juntan,
y que nos gustan las personas que son como nosotros.
Pregunta seis:
Mis compañeros de trabajo flirtean y eso me molesta.
¿Qué debo hacer?
Algunos investigadores argumentan que quienes flirtean en el trabajo
se benefician y aumentan su creatividad.
Pero mi propia investigación sugiere que las cosas son diferentes
para quienes observan un flirteo o son objetos de él.
Puede ser incómodo, ¿verdad?
Ser testigo de un flirteo en el trabajo crea la sensación
de no conocer las reglas, de no saber qué pasa
o tal vez de ver algo que no deberías ver.
Quienes presencian con frecuencia un flirteo en el trabajo
manifiestan sentirse menos satisfechos en sus trabajos,
y se sienten menos valorados por su empresa.
Es más probable que vean de forma negativa el ambiente de trabajo,
e incluso pueden pensar en renunciar.
Para las mujeres, esta asociación puede ser aún más fuerte.
Este parece ser el caso
incluso cuando las personas afirman no sentirse molestas por el flirteo.
Es cierto incluso cuando dicen que lo disfrutan.
En resumen, un ambiente de flirteo realmente puede ser tóxico.
Pregunta siete:
¿Necesito una política sobre las relaciones laborales?
Sin duda necesitas una política sobre acoso sexual,
y en Recursos Humanos la mayoría lo reconoce.
Pero para el tipo de comportamiento consensual del que hemos hablado,
no aplica.
Aun cuando a las personas de RRHH les encantaría agitar una varita mágica
y decir: "No te enamorarás en el trabajo",
simplemente no es realista.
La conexión emocional y la sexualidad es lo que somos.
Ahora quisiera que veas la otra cara.
Aliento a los de RRHH a pensar de manera más amplia
acerca de su papel, y no necesariamente en erradicar el romance de oficina,
porque no creo que sea realista,
sino en cómo crear un clima y una cultura de trabajo
donde las personas se sientan respetadas por sus contribuciones individuales,
y no por su apariencia, su género,
o sus relaciones personales.
Así que la gran pregunta es:
¿Cómo nos aseguramos
de que las personas sean valoradas y respetadas?